but we had such a successful birthday
last Oh last week
whose birthday was that oh my god okay
it was our your shipmates birthdays are
live first ship's birthday first live
podcast that we haven't talked about
nobody knows this is the podcast I want
to say this may I say something
yes you may what a surprise what a night
I went to a place that they held
auditions for something industrial film
for some Southwest Airline thing so that
you walk in and there's people signing
up to audition and we had our podcast in
an audition room so when I first showed
up there I was gonna you're grumpy
grumpy I was gonna burn the place down
but when I walked in it changed
everything and it made me feel gleeful
and really excited about what was doing
what was it like I saw a bunch of people
that really liked our podcast and that
um it makes me want to cry right now but
you know that and then and the podcast
was fun I got to talk to people and
whatnot and then this weekend I was at
the new left D live comedy club in
Oxnard and these two kids from Long
Beach who our target really fans showed
up and they took them to Denny's
afterwards but the reason why I did is
because anybody that listens in this
podcast is a different fan than regular
fans they're more family than other ones
how great was every single person in
that room last week awesome I mean
everybody was just amazing kind
fun and they were funny
yeah you know and they were smart
and they were just very like interactive
and you know some there were a few that
were were introverted but you can tell
like the wheels were spinning in their
head yeah it was such a fun
bunch oh good he's a really good there
was that half Latino girl in the front
she was cool
Bianca Bianca that the white dude that
brought the pizza there was maybe from
the law office from San Diego oh yeah
Sarah yeah yeah you know all the names I
it's crazy how I know them all by name
also Jo the one who's but Bobby wanted
to climb into the big guy yeah it was a
guy in there he had he was a big guy
yeah returned returned the other time
and I wanted to just open open his butt
cheeks and walk in not metaphorically
and not in a sexual way but just enough
he was a very pillowy very very
welcoming like his his body you just
definitely want to lay in yeah that was
a very good um a very nice experience
and in general tiger belly fans have
been just a delight nothing but
supportive they get occasionally you get
they get the they don't know how to
express their love so they say mean
things but George and I came up with a
conclusion that's people just expressed
love in different ways in different ways
so if they even if it's something that
may seemingly be offensive
they're just that's their way of showing
interest in you and I'm okay with that
yeah and even like Jay did the weekend
with me at levity live and a lot of
tiger belly fans obviously like her and
she I would like to really do a podcast
with kalila Jade and AUSA or something
they're all woman's podcast
ya know be your honorary woman no I'd
want to do it I want to produce it but I
would like to be there but I don't want
to be on it beat out the view
[Music]